those
who are driven by
force
are more ambitious
on imposing
and having control
than those who are driven by choice let
me unpack this meaning
you know sometimes people that are
driven by force are more
inspired to get involved in politics and
create laws than those who are driven by
choice choice is kind of like listen let
me leave me alone let me let me go live
my life right but i think sometimes it's
kind of like
you know you made this one example you
know
who made this example somebody was on
yesterday saying look
you know the way i look at foreign
relations my gritline is if i go to a
bar
and if a fights break in into a bar and
i go in there no matter what if i go in
there and fight i'm going to piss off
one side whether i fight defend the girl
or the guy someone's going to be upset
with me because i chose to fight right
it says america is kind of like that
you're getting into a lot of these
fights and you're getting involved in
these there's a fight going on your
country right now yours
and
people are still listening to this guy
he's still got influence
and you got you know you know these
truckers that are coming out there are
saying listen you can't make us do this
5 500 mile america this you want us to
get vaccinated you wanna say we don't
wanna do it we want this freedom
don't you think
you know
this may be a good time for you to throw
your name in the you know and say hey
you know what i'm gonna go and here's
why because i think a hundred years from
when we sit here and talk about who was
the main philosopher when lincoln was
president
only people in that world are going to
know who that person is but everyone's
going to know who lincoln is and what
lincoln did and the impact he made right
do i think his life was a you know a
peaceful life if you've read about
lincoln and his marriage and that one
friend he would travel with and when you
go to smithsonian then they show the
evolution of how much he aged it's a
pretty it's a lot of burden of what this
guy went through right but he was chosen
and he was the right guy for it
you don't at all feel like
you know
no it's again i think
i can detail out some of the reasons
sure i think i'm more effective doing
what i'm doing well i'm working with a
lot of political people in the united
states both on the republican and the
democrat side all the time and i
couldn't do that if i was
involved
formally and technically in politics in
canada i'm working with a bunch of
people in the uk as well
and so and i'm working with people in
canada it's just more effective for me
to do what i'm doing i don't know about
that
i don't know well i can give you an
example with the truckers you know so
and a couple of examples so
a week and a half ago
the former premier of newfoundland so
equivalent of the governor of the state
he was the premier in in the 1980s
and uh he was one of the drafters of the
canadian charter of rights so he
actually wrote it with a bunch of other
people but he was one of them and he's a
mainstream solidly admired politician
across the spectrum regarded as a decent
guy
and he mounted a constitutional
challenge to
the vaccine mandates
announced it a week ago
stating that see they put an emergency
provision in the charter saying that
under certain emergency conditions true
emergencies that charter rights could be
suspended in the case of a national
emergency but he's not convinced in the
least that
the kovid epidemic even at its height
constituted such an emergency he said
that was not the intent of the drafters
and certainly doesn't constitute that
emergency now
and
so he talked me through this and i
thought well isn't this interesting we
have a person who actually drafted the
chart of rights saying that the and a
former premier of a major province
saying that the government is acting in
an essentially unconstitutional manner i
don't think that's ever happened in the
history of a western democracy
and i said well
okay that's
something
he's 82 now sharp as attack
why do you want to announce this on my
podcast
because
that's
preposterous and he said well our team
has talked it over and we don't think
there's one news source in canada that
will handle this credibly
i thought that's not good so we released
that a week and a half ago which was
timed very nicely as it turned out with
the trucker's protest
because people are saying well are the
truckers breaking the law
and the question is well just exactly
who's breaking law here
and that's by no means obvious
and so that was extremely helpful and
then about
a few days after that i
released another video
calling on the conservative types in
canada to seize the moment
given this popular uprising and the fact
that countries all over the world are
dropping the covid
mandates
to seize the moment and drop the
mandates at a provincial level it's
enough is enough and
somebody's got to be the first actor and
so that got million and a half views in
no time flat and
so i'm able to play a useful role
as a well on the media front weirdly
enough but also as a
someone who's standing apart from the
from the details of the political fray
i mean i get that but you know it's like
saying
if reagan would have stayed being the b
actor or a ge going getting paid a
million dollars a year to go around the
world and talking about his political
philosophies and how great he is or
president of sag would he have been able
to tell gorbachev to take that wall down
i don't think so would he have
influenced a country like russia to
become a little bit more free where
people are staying they're not leaving
they're a little bit more comfortable
staying there because now there's a
capitalistic opportunity it's no longer
communism car marks and angle and those
guys don't have the influence that they
had before because stalin and lenin and
what travesty they did to people does
that credit go to gorbachev does it go
to who it goes to reagan right so if you
think about churchill and chamberlain it
goes to solzhenitsyn too i i told again
he was a right obviously a writer and so
it's look i mean it's not like you know
what i'm saying there isn't it's not
like
the the political domain doesn't have
its purpose and its function
and but
there's a lot i would have to stop doing
if i did that and it isn't obvious to me
that that's the right thing for me to do
partly again because
i
started doing what i'm doing back in say
probably 1985
because i realized that
one of the pathways to totalitarian
catastrophe was
deceit at the individual level this is
something that soldier nits and made
very much of orwell as well huxley as
well these great thinkers
concluded
in the aftermath of these totalitarian
catastrophes that there was an integral
link between
pathology at the individual level which
was fundamentally the willingness to use
deceit in an instrumental manner i'll
lie to you to get what i want and
authoritarian catastrophe and that it
was a direct causal link and actually by
that argument i think that's literally
true and so partly what i'm doing i hope
is
helping people walk through
thinking about why telling the truth is
a good idea
not not only for them
not not as a top down shake your finger
moral injunction don't lie you shouldn't
lie
but in an in a detailed manner to
explain the relationship between the
instrumental use of deceit and the
collapse of civilizations and that
connection is way closer than people
think you know so
one person is influenced as a thousand
people for sure in their lifetime and
sometimes a lot more than that and
a thousand you know the next rung out
from that a thousand times a thousand is
a million and the next rung out from
that is a billion and so you're always
at the center of a concentric circle
that two rungs out contains a billion
people
well it turns out that what you do
matters and
basically what i'm doing as i hope
is touring and talking to people
face to face in these lectures for
example and making the case that
it's a terrifying case everyone says
well we want meaning in our life it's
do you now
do you now because you might ask
yourself what's the more threatening
possibility that nothing you do matters
which means you can pretty much do
whatever you want that's the upside of
that nihilistic claim no responsibility
right and why why not pursue narrow
focused hedonism since nothing matters
anyways so that's the shadow of nihilism
or everything you do matters
and it's a lot more
terrifying to contemplate that is that
you will be held accountable for
everything you do and i believe that
firmly partly as a consequence of my
clinical experience i never saw
any one of my clinical clients
ever get away with anything
even once
and you think well people get away with
things all the time it's like no they
don't
they might
gain
a narrow advantage
in one dimension in the short term
but
you know let's say that you you're you
use deceit in your business practices
first of all that doesn't work very well
because people will figure you out so as
a long-term
as a long-term strategy it's terrible it
just doesn't work no one is going to
play with you if you're a cheat but
let's say
that someone asked me someone asked me
the other day well what about these
dictators that that uh you know ruled
their whole life and and they were at
the top of the hierarchy let's say and
they had all the power stalin's a
perfectly good example it's like
didn't he win
well
everyone stalin ever talked to lied to
him because they were absolutely bloody
terrified of him his country was a
nightmare
it was a hell or as close as we've been
able to produce with the possible
exception of the nazis and the maoists
but it was up there in terms of hell and
did he rule
yes but he ruled hell and if you think
that's a victory well go ahead and try
it see how much of a victory it is
you know milton satan said i'd rather
rule in hell than serve in heaven it's
like fair enough go ahead use deceit use
instrumentality rule in hell you'll be
the ruler see how much good it does you
see where that takes you it takes you
somewhere terrible and so
i'm much more interested in talking
those things through with people and i
do do political work but
but
i it's not the right thing for me so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]